hey and welcome to episode 105 today I'm
going to build this little building but
that is definitely not the most amazing
thing that's going to happen in this
episode the major thing is that I'm
going to be supporting the roller
coaster which was actually kind of a
funny thing since the idea of how the
roller coaster as a whole should be
actually changed while I was supporting
it but that's the story for at some
other point in this video first I should
probably talk about this house this was
the second house and I also didn't
really look at anything in real life of
how I should do things in particular
when it comes to the English theme and I
must also say that I have my doubts
about how well this building in the end
actually reflects the English theme I am
NOT going to keep this texture by the
way which it has at the moment which is
that it i think it's from the dutch sets
i figured i could try it since it does
have a stone texture and also had some
of the pieces that i needed but in the
end that really just didn't work so i
did make the walls brown in the end but
even then I still feel like I haven't
really captured the English
architectural style as a whole in this
building and I would like to look at it
it's hide a bit more later on when i get
to the other buildings but expect from
me that in the next couple of episodes
i'll try to not do too many things that
are new to me when it comes to the
buildings and actually try some other
things it's gonna be a lot of paths
works a little foliage and actually
doing something really special with a
flat right but also talk about that at
some point later on when that is
actually going to happen so yeah this
building itself is not really too
special that i must add the way that I
built it was still looking at google
images are trying to find houses in
london and see what i can get
inspiration from and I did get
inspiration from image houses and kind
of decided to make it after that but the
problem is that you can really recognize
the fact that i took windows and also
it's a props of the buildings from
different sets and there is no real
distinct english theme to them so even
though they were modeled after English
houses so they have a similar build up
overall a similar color scheme
use of materials the details themselves
are just some things that I'm not too
sure about at the moment for example I
found some really unique Victorian and
gothic windows and many houses that you
just don't have in Walla koseki 3 i've
never found it cuz some scenery sets
that have windows like the windows now i
have found on American English houses
that i found a google images so it's
really hard to even come up with
anything to do about that so it is
probably very inevitable that I'm gonna
have to make some simple customs in
readjust to make it work a tiny bit just
like for the touch area but before I cut
to do that I just like to procrastinate
and do other things that I just feel
like doing more which also means that I
mean this might sound like the overall
layouts and planning of this area is not
as important as getting the architecture
right and I would definitely not say
that that is the case it is very
important to me to get the overall shape
and design of this area to be very good
so they're both very important things I
just feel like the architecture is
something that I am completely failing
on and well not completely failing on
but something that I don't feel like I
can do in the future without doing some
more research / making some custom
scenery because I just find so many
things that I can't do in what like a
second three at the moment and the thing
is there is a certain level of realism
that I do want to have I can probably
make buildings that sort of resemble the
English theme with what I currently have
but it just isn't realistic enough for
what I'm going for so that is why I at
that point decided okay screw this
entire building a building thing let's
just do some supports for the roller
coaster and this is where the entire
idea of this roller coaster changed
because i have probably stressed this
quite a bit too much but the idea that i
went for with this roller coaster was I
wanted to do something really hipster
ish I've never ever seen an intimate
stand up in real life be really well
themed I mean only two in the world
maybe even one I don't know but there
are rare occurrence and they're not
or anything and I don't think I've ever
seen somebody in veliko second three
make an intimate stand up and actually
have a lot of theming around it and kind
of put a lot of effort into it in that
way so I wanted to do that but then I
got to the support structure for the
lift so analyzers really really felt
like making some B&M supports and that
is how this is now a B&M stand up it's
religious doesn't even mean anything
it's exactly the same track it is pretty
much the same cause so it really doesn't
even matter that much but intamin stand
up was just the ultimate hipster idea
but in the end interesting workouts
because I didn't feel like doing it and
so this is now a binam stand up and that
being said though this is still quite a
unique B&M stand up when you compare
them to the ones in real life since body
the first thing that is really unique
about it is the cobra roll that is
something that doesn't even exist in
real life on stand ups but there's also
the first drop which has a very large
extensive sort of pre drop and how the
pre drop is almost larger than drop
itself but it isn't but the pre drop is
very large in this right and it's both
kind of their to function as a pretty
drop as well as being a signature
elements on the right i said that i
liked the skyline of the roller coaster
at some point at which people were
laughing at the time because it's not
really a skyline but the general idea is
that you walk around here in the past
and you have that view of the roller
coaster in the distance and just with
the right supports I live so can look so
much more menacing than just a boring
book strike supports or I lived here
with boring straight supports and that's
why I wanted to go for these supports
this also leads me some room underneath
the track that I can fit in the queue
line so that's also really handy the
footprint is a lot smaller on these
supports for anybody by the way I didn't
not even mention this but I didn't even
make the difference clear but on a
intimate stand up you would normally
just have normal straights supports
underneath the lift Hill but what is
what a very bnm sort of thing to do is
is to have these supports under lift
and have for example three different
supports or connected one foot in the
way that you can see it over here two
supports on the top of the lift Hill are
connected to one for two and the three
supports in the MIT in the middle are
all connecting to one foot as well and
that is just a very be a mish thing to
do and I just like the look of that sort
of Twitter make up a lot more than just
straight footers and that's why I kind
of wanted to do like that and that's why
I should refer to this thing as a B&M
stand up now because it is very very
unlikely that beer intimate would ever
make a stand up coaster that would have
this sort of support structure and
that's why I kind of wanted to stress
that a tiny bit and after that the
normal sort of work just kind of
continued after the supports the rest of
the supports aren't really too special
it's a pretty low lying co sexually as a
lot of it just being alerted rain and
doing helixes and many curves people
people did throw multiple times at me
still that this thing is going to be
quite uncomfortable to which I can still
say it's a stand-up goes through it is
going to be uncomfortable anyway um
you're gonna foster your seatbelts
anyway and be ready for a heavy ride so
I don't really mind that too much here's
a little fun thing by the way actually I
had some more ideas with it but I didn't
really work out you know those kind of
arches right a gardens where you have
like rose bushes that grow all of those
all over those arches and you get an
amazing walkway with roses all around
you I kind of wanted to steal from the
idea and make a little flower thing
though only problem was there are no
flowers that kind of go round our things
so eventually it turned out to be just
finds and that's that basically I am
going out of my way to get as many
unique sort of gardening traits into
these planters as i can because a very
common pitfall is that when you have
many planters all around one area and
you're all going to do the foliage of
them at once that all the all the plants
are basically going to have exactly the
same foliage and i really did not want
that whatsoever so when it's got a
different sort of style in for every
little area and see how that would go
now now i started on a new thing which i
said in the
beginning of this episode that are we
talking about later and that's actually
this little carousel which is sort of a
building not really it is in the overall
victorian style and it's really just a
roof for the teacups and of course i did
get tea cups into the english area I if
I don't get tea cups into this area I
would be just that would be the most
stupid things if there is one flat ride
that I should have in the English area I
should probably be teacups otherwise
i'll probably get some crumpets that
throne to my head by some brits so i
needed to get the tea cups in there and
figured i could get a roof from existing
completes because some scenery sets in
there but i wanted to mess around with a
simple victorian style roof the initial
idea was to make it a lot smaller than
this is but then i place the teacups and
realize that the teacups ride was quite
a bit larger than i expected and decided
to just get that middle dome and then
place cornices very far away from that
so i would have enough clearance for the
ride itself and then just see how it
would work out so it was quite a bit of
an experiment this thing I was hoping
that it would work out and I think in
the end I'm quite happy about this thing
actually it's not too special really
simple in the shape and form and it's
definitely mostly in the details that it
was harder to get this done right but um
this is something I always kind of enjoy
because you can get there are many sets
that you had that exists that can give
you pieces for any sort of iron works or
victorian style buildings so never
really run into too many problems of
limitations when it comes to continue
that you can use and it's really one of
these things where you don't really have
to worry about the overall shape of the
building you just skim through sets and
add details upon details upon details
and make it look like one big
sugar-coated pie and that's pretty much
what this building is in the end a
sugar-coated pie but I do like it the
only thing which I am not so sure about
is the placement right here it's it's it
feels like this thing wants to be in the
middle of pots and once I've paths all
around it with all sorts of gardening
and pot ornaments the only problem is if
I move this thing outward into the paths
and actually
built spots or run this thing I would be
obstructing the facades that I want to
have in the future in this area and I
would also make this area way too large
that would mean that everything had to
move up a couple of tiles and I feel
like I just can't use that especially
considering that then the English area
would be way larger than it is already
so it is a bit kind of tucked into the
corner of the roller coaster and the
exit is going to be awkwardly text
underneath at the little bunny hope that
the roller coaster has but other than
the fact that it may be looking a bit
cramped I don't really have too many
problems with it and overall I do like
the building in any case that's it for
this episode to see that I'm running out
of time again so thank you guys for
watching I'll see you guys later see you
space cowboys